to be honest I'm normally like white
wine Rosa is cool Rosa is cool Rose I
think random that gives me a headache
Rosa feels like something somebody got
bored and invented that Minh didn't need
you know we had white wine we had red
wine and then somebody got creative it
came up with Rosa it always feels that
way the next morning my I didn't need
that glass of Rose oh hey what's up DQ
super duper Kyle here and I wanted to
share ten of my essentials with y'all
first essential item okay it is Louis
Vuitton lemon Ness it I don't know how
to say that I don't even go anywhere not
spread this all myself you know because
I'm trying to you know I'm gonna make I
want to make my lady huh you know I'm
gonna make myself happy I want to make
my dog happy my fiancee actually got it
for me for Christmas and before that I
didn't really have a ton of Cologne like
that honestly when I was a kid I was
broke right so you had to use this clone
called curve not that curve is bad it's
just that when you yourself are broken
you go to school with all the other
broken and you all can only afford the
one cologne so we always the school
smell my curve so got to the point where
it wasn't even like you were wearing
Cologne it was just like he was smelling
regular and after that I was pretty
scarred from Colona
ever wanted to be a part of it but it
was the best gift I've ever gotten here
it is this is my Cologne take a look at
all its wonder well that's my initials
on it says KH very very important that
you have caffeine it can come in any
form this here is green tea which I love
also coffee coffee is extremely
important when you're waking up at home
that first hour is crucial to how your
day is gonna go if you don't have coffee
or tea you know for sure your day is
going wrong there's no time today where
caffeine and get stop I've got studio
sessions before where I'm just not gonna
cup of coffee at like 3 a.m. sometimes
though I'll check myself at like 7 p.m.
maybe like ok bro chill I'm talking
about instant coffee a pack of just pure
white sugar in there mix it around with
skim milk ahh don't care I don't like
fancy anything I also sort of believe
that like when you eat dads that like
when you don't care about having fancy
stuff your entire life your body becomes
like sort of immune to it you know so I
think I can drink gas station coffee and
I can drink like $20,000 coffee and I'm
gonna get the same thing for me an
essential item for making every night
right at home is a glass of wine similar
to my caffeine
preferences I don't necessarily know the
difference between really good wine and
really trashed wine because I sort of
enjoy
both I can get a bottle of opus and just
think I'm on fire and I can also get a
bottle of this thing called red truck
and that's amazing so I don't
necessarily have like a crazy preference
rose' is cool Rosie feels like something
somebody got bored and Bennet that we
didn't meet you know we had white wine
we had red wine and then somebody got
creative and came over Rosie it always
feels that way the next morning like I
didn't need that glass of rose a who
boom right here people your xbox this is
damn they're more essential than every
other item on this list me I'm a big
gamer I love video games always have
always will
and my day is not completed if I don't
at least get like some type of gaming
and you know I mean I need at least two
hours
actually I restrained two hours a day on
Twitter if you want to check that out I
don't know for me it's like always been
like a release and like an escape
sort of if you don't like your situation
at home you can sort of jump into this
little portal that is games and
disappear I would say my favorite game
ever for Xbox has got to be probably the
Elder Scrolls franchise it's just like
an endless world you know if you wanted
to say what's up to every single person
that was in that game that would take
you years you know so I love that game
second on that list is the Halo
franchise you know a lot of people hate
on hail
nowadays but you still gotta give them
their credit in dead twos like grant a
bottle of course you know you can't
really you can't overlook grandpa
grandpa bottles been amazing three years
a year so I love them - Kay - I'm Nastya
- KC I play 2k less for like button is
more of like competitive spirit you know
today we're gonna play a 2k I've gotta
destroy somebody are you a FIFA no I'm
not a fever guy that's the same dudes
that go to college for finance you know
I mean like next time you see somebody
playing Fifa ask them what they studied
in college finance boom you know another
very important part of my essential
day-to-day life this is a sure
microphone and sm7 I mean essential to
me delivering you guys is also using you
can pretty much use it anywhere at any
time super portable I'm talking about we
could be in the middle like above a
sailboat you know in the perfect storm
and as long as you have a computer and
something to record on this microphone
is gonna work perfectly normally what I
do is I just load this bad boy up I have
my glass of red wine I'm walking some
type of movie with the sound off some
credible meat is being played and I just
normally start like freestyling is
coming like little ideas as I walk
around a Fred I heard something
somewhere that I read something
somewhere which is not that credible of
a source but whatever that dogs actually
like music and so every time I'm
starting to sing you're like making
songs and playing the piano or something
I noticed my dog I have a little poodles
name is Frodo he randomly always is like
sort of excited you know sounds like
it's really nice like sort of half smile
on his face it's great because he's not
that judgmental I could be making a
terrible song and I think Frodo still
loves it all right boom next essential a
Nintendo switch okay so I'm like a
Nintendo stands I think everybody my age
younger above me like literally they
have the dead
of so many age groups that they were the
first video game console that those
people played cool thing about the
switch is it is all the awesome things
that an Xbox or Playstation or something
like that provides right here in your
hand and if you're talking about
portability like you put it on the plane
you play it in the car you can play it
in bed you can play as a rocket
scientist you can take this thing
anywhere any situation you know it's
funny I want an animal crossing when I
was a little kid like so bad and I
didn't have a 64 so I never got into it
and now it just came back and I'm keep
thinking I'm like dipping my toe into
like the pool of like who do I want to
really like I'm trying to be productive
do I want to spend all my time on Animal
Crossing right now the MacBook Pro baby
yes sir
when I was younger I always was on PCs I
feel like everybody had a PC and then
there was those Mac people you know the
Mac people they've moved a certain way
they talked to a certain way you know
these weird looks that were like have
you ever done your own taxes you know
they kind of had a strange vibe to them
then I got my first MacBook Pro and my
life was changed forever and I was like
oh I totally get it you're not getting
down one of them I'm productive I'm
smart but not in all seriousness this is
one of the most essential parts of my
life because everything I do for my
career everything I do for my art my
passion all comes from this thing I use
this program on here called a mixed inky
but you can take any beat any note any
piece of audio you put it in there it
tells you the tempo and it tells you the
key and that way you can load up your
auto-tune I'm sorry if you're watching
this Quincy Jones I feel I gotta let you
down because we don't we can't hear
something just dedicated a song
somewhere that doesn't happen the air
pods
it's almost like the most essential
piece to my most essential pieces I love
these things they have completely
changed my life just losing the wire
system shouldn't make that big of a deal
but it really does it's walking down the
street I'm fully focused I can take
meetings I can listen to an album I can
watch a TV show I can transport to like
any world just because I have these
earphones the only thing that they need
to fix is out easy they are you lose
I'll listen them using some other
headphones sometimes and even though
they're like supposed to be more due to
your quality or whatever the way that
the sound is makes that comes out of
these is a little more enjoyable to me
they just think I'm even using them to
do my essential list that's how
essential they are the greatest shoe
ever invented this is the essence of a
shoe like if somebody's like what is a
shoe you show them this it's not doing
anything boards not doing anything less
it's doing just what it wants to do and
it's looking good while doing it a baby
and grandpa anybody can wear this I'm
gonna wear this shoe and on a tee and
I'm gonna look tight I'm gonna look cool
as hell I have a whole plethora advance
I can probably wear a different pair of
bands every day for
because thanks so much I love this shoe
also my very first job I ever had was
working at bands and I remember they
gave me a pair of bands for free and I
damn near cried I get the store like oh
my god like Everly years of college I
had bands before they even brought the
retro cool bands back that's how you can
tell if somebody is a true band
supporter like did you wear bands before
they reintroduced to these I had the
chunky bands you know me I had the big
goofy ones I was there if you did it
your questionable you shake your own
thin bands supporting ice sorry that I
get so excited over your shoes but bands
next essential item is some snazzy car
merchandise in filming so this is a
piece of yes merchandise from a new
single feature never educated K camp
I'm one of those people who really sort
of likes to wear their own clothes and
it's not a narcissism thing at all or at
least I don't think it is it's just
having some of my own like merchandise
on hand there's always sort of like a
creative project for me you know
obviously look at it analyze it see what
I like about it see how it fits you know
where is a big picture stuff too like
really trying to like map out in the
long run what like your brand will turn
into and try to make you something more
personal to me and like my hometown of
antara sort of like the lifestyle brand
so I grew up on whether it's bands or
like things like that and that's the
thing if you are a cool person you know
that bands are the great issue ever and
then you can go ahead and do something
like this you know boom now look out yo
I mean it's too good and then another
very essential item for me recently has
been this new puka shell choker chain
I've gotten I'm taking the beach vibe
with me wherever I go I can be an
article with this thing and feel warm I
sorta always kind of like the whole like
Beach
aesthetic look and I start thinking like
damn if I'm spending money on these
chains I always want to make sure
there's something that I feel like
represents me I have a iced out one on
the way that I'm really excited about
and then I got held up due to recent
events so in the meantime I had my
assistant Michael merchant find this
very awesome puka shell one so shout out
to you Mike and it's like really like a
shell necklace like it's kind of like
held up by like these strings and you
can just like adjust them and this is
one it's just a gold one but hey gold is
late too you know I mean gold is like
can't complain about gold you know
Hey GQ thank you for spending the time
with me thanks for hanging out that's it
it's all my essentials I will see you
next time